the New York Times however is now
starting to acknowledge that like some
of the Nazi symbols on the front line of
the Ukraine are a bit confusing Nazi
symbols on Ukraine's front lines
highlight thorny issues of History I
there's nothing better than the word
thorny the newspaper of record the fact
that they have to do this the fact that
they're even taught it means there's
more coming down the pike I'm
telling you I've been in a game a while
if they have to do this it means that
there's more stuff coming down the bike
they're getting out in front of it
they're trying to get ahead of it
because there's more stuff coming if
they're if they're writing an article
about fashion in the middle of a
counter-offensive it means that there's
more coming